c'est la conséquence de l'application de
la Constitution de la Cinquième
République et il a sans doute oublié que
à l'époque la gauche s'ouvre-françois
Hollande dans son quinquennat ici au
Sénat avec utilisé à 9 reprises ce vote
bloqué nous on veut aller au fond et on
va aller au bout pour voter et la gauche
est mauvaise expérience perdant puisque
ils sentent bien qu'ils sont en minorité
évidemment sur ce texte donc ils veulent
à tout prix nous empêcher empêcher la
majorité de voter ça c'est pas la
démocratie ça on peut pas tolérer avec
une obstruction que je n'ai jamais vu
depuis 20 ans au Sénat ils ont créé une
sorte d'industrialisation de
l'obstruction mais on peut pas vis-à-vis
d’une majorité que nous représentons se
faire prendre en otage par une minorité
ça c'est pas la démocratie vous voyez
nous on va aller au fond et on veut
discuter rendez compte je l'ai souligné
440 neuf demande de rapport qui ont été
déposés des amendements des amendements
et à chaque fois un amant seulement de
sous amendement c'est-à-dire que on
aurait pu ajouter 10 jours 15 jours à
chaque fois il y aurait eu la machine à
sous amender des amendements totalement
ridicules qui ne sont pas des
amendements des sous amendements au fond
c'est ça l'obstruction bien contre
l'obstruction il y a le règlement du
Sénat mais qui n'y suffit pas il y a
aussi les articles de la Constitution on
est sous la Cinquième République pas
sous la Quatrième République ici au
Sénat c'est pas la rue qui fait la loi
la loi c'est la démocratie
représentative il y a le droit de grève
on a le droit de manifester dans le
calme bien sûr pacifiquement je le
reconnecte complètement mais ici notre
job c'est pas seulement de parler à
l'infini notre job c'est de voter mais
après ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
est-ce que ce vote bloqué sa fragilise
pas la réforme sa légitimité non on est
déjà l'article 9 on a fait passer des
marqueurs qui sont pour nous très très
importants et en réalité il reste
quelques articles puisque sur les 20
articles de la réforme la réforme tient
en 13 articles les derniers articles ce
sont des articles techniques que vous
retrouvez dans les lois de finances des
tableaux d'équilibre qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'essentiel le cœur de la
réforme donc je pense que on peut
continuer à aller au bout de ce texte il
le faut impérativement en discutant du
fond ça sert à rien de discuter des
sous-amendements qui par dizaines par
centaines sont déposées et qui leur rien
dire on déplace d'un jour un rapport
qu'il faut déposer à tel moment etc etc
nous on va aller au fond on veut
débattre par exemple de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants tous ceux
qui ont des enfants handicapés chez eux
des parents ils sont des aidants il y en
a 4 millions en France avec
l'obstruction de la gauche on y arrive
pas on y arrive pas nous on veut
vraiment discuter de chaque article
utile de la loi pour améliorer la loi
pour améliorer
est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui la
certitude que ils font partie des
amendements retenus par le gouvernement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
lesquels ont été retenues de tête très
franchement il y a eu une langue
libération des ministres vous allez me
permettre quand même de les étudier les
plus importants on en a fait beaucoup
passer on a fait passer le CDI senior on
a fait passer ce que j'ai toujours
appelé la vraie ligne rouge c'est nous
qui avons porté et non pas l'Assemblée
nationale et non pas la gauche ici
l'injustice fait au maire de famille qui
était les vrais perdante de cette
réforme c'est nous la gauche a raillé
évidemment cette droite cette droite
ringarde qui voulait parler pour les
maires de famille résultat notre
amendement il a passé hier sans aucune
voix contre sans aucune voix quand je
m'en réjouis il y a d'autres amendements
j'espère bien qu'on va les faire passer
notamment sur la pénibilité sur l'usure
professionnelle et celui sur la fin et
sur la sur les régimes spéciaux voilà
l'obstruction de la gauche il nous avait
sur cette sur ce sous amendement qui
était le mien
accroché 250 sous amendements pour faire
en sorte d'embourber totalement le débat
je sais très bien depuis le départ que
c'est amendement le gouvernement n'en
voulait pas et c'est bien dommage il a
par le gouvernement j'imagine qu'il n'a
il n'aura pas été retenu encore une fois
j'ai pas vraiment vérifier les numéros
d'amendement qui ont été appelés puisque
ça s'est pas passé par nature par nom de
l'amendement mais par numéro
régimes spéciaux donc mais vous décidez
de ne pas toucher à votre propre régime
autonome pourquoi demander aux Français
de faire des efforts alors que vous vous
décidez pas en faire mais c'est faux
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire ça
j'ai relâché cet engagé à traduire un
certain nombre de règles dans notre
propre régime autonome qui n'est pas un
régime spécial d'ailleurs puisque si
c'était un régime spécial on aurait des
règles par exemple de départ d'âge légal
différent et on aurait des subventions
massives de l'État simplement c'est une
caisse autonome et on a décidé de
cotiser de surcotiser à hauteur de 20%
les députés c'est par exemple 14% donc
on va s'appliquer aussi ses règles il
est très difficile de savoir comment
on parle on parle du 49 et bien c'est
parfaitement transparent c'est l'argent
c'est la cotisation des sénateurs c'est
la cotisation des sénateurs voilà c'est
la cotisation de sénateur on cotise à
hauteur de 20% public c'est la
cotisation uniquement de l'employeur
quand on est élu madame allez-y
est-ce que vous attendez à ça est-ce que
c'est à mes collègues députés qu'il faut
le demander j'ai utilisé ce matin une
métaphore pour la première ministre en
disant soit c'est la roulette russe
c'est-à-dire il y a pas de 49-3 elle
essaie de faire en sorte que elle a une
majorité auquel cas elle fait ce pari ça
peut être un pari bien calculé mais
aujourd'hui ça ressemble un peu à la
route à la roulette russe soit c'est le
49-3 c'est-à-dire la Grosse Bertha et
aujourd'hui moi je ne sais pas dire je
suis sénateur je suis président d'un
groupe au Sénat et je ne sais pas dire
qu'elle peut-être demain une majorité
pour ce texte là-bas à l'Assemblée
nationale
c'est là où on a du mal à suivre la
ligne de votre partie aujourd'hui vous
vous faites tout pour voter cette loi
eux nous explique qu'ils n'auront pas
les voies suffisantes pour donner la
majorité au gouvernement les députés de
votre partie on a un peu du mal à suivre
la ligne de votre de votre partie
aujourd'hui du parti elle est très
claire la direction qui Olivier Marleix
et moi-même nous l'avons exprimé à
plusieurs reprises 61 députés est-ce
qu'il y aura l'abstention le con de 15
ou de 20 j'observe que le gros de
l'équipe de Olivier Marleix votre
apourse cette réforme est-ce que ça
suffira moi je ne sais pas je peux pas
faire des comptes d'un petit Caire
aujourd'hui d'ici en plus du Sénat
moi j'ai toujours dit ici que
on peut pas varier je pense que ce qui a
beaucoup abîmé les LR c'est nos recul
nous revirements de quoi aurions-nous
l'air si nous ne votion pas ce texte 64
ans alors que depuis des années on
soutient en 65 ans il faut améliorer le
texte les députés l'ont fait nous
l'avons fait collectivement sur les
petites pensions sur les carrières
longues nous faisons aussi par exemple
sur les maires de famille je pense que
la politique même quand c'est pas
populaire c'est dire la vérité aux
Français et la vérité aux Français c'est
que on a un choc démographique sans
précédent c'est plus le baby-boom c'est
le papy boom c'est à dire qu'on va
multiplier par 4 par 5 le nombre de
françaises de Français qui vont entrer
dans la période de la retraite comment
fait-on pour financer tout ça comment
fait-on si on accepte pas de travailler
un peu plus et bien on fait exploser le
régime par répartition et je voudrais
simplement dire que en 2030 quand cette
réforme s'appliquera nous serons le pays
d'Europe où on partira le plutôt en
retraite nous serons le pays d'Europe où
nous aurons le meilleur régime de
carrière longue de toute l'Europe